Mark: You guys sure you wanna do this Let's Play?!
Wade: No!
Mark: Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Genital Jousting!
Here's a big flashy warning!
Mark: There's penises!
And dicks in butts!
Bob: I didn't even look, it's called Online Multipeen!
Mark: Oh, no.
Alright, but we don't need to do online, we got our friends right here.
And so while we're playing this we're gonna imagine this is going to happen....
*mumbling and confused Wade*
Mark: I'll stop that train of thought right then and there!
Wade: Thank you!
Mark: I will stop it RIGHT NOW.
Bob: Are you saying this is planning for later tonight?
Mark: No, I'm saying we're well-experienced in this game, because we've done this before.
Bob: Oh, so we're gonna all be very good at this?
Wade: The "G" wiggling makes me uncomfortable.
Mark: The little sassy "G" WAGGLE!
And the "L" waggles like, "Nuh, uh, uh!" *laughter*
Mark: Alright everybody, we're gonna try to do-
We've never played this. Wade has never even seen it.
Wade: No, this is as much as I've ever seen of this game.
Mark: "Hold up to consent."
Bob: Hold up to consent!
*laughter*
Mark: Oh, no!
Well, there goes the concern of the consent.
All: Oh, no.
Bob: Well, we're all consenting adults...
All: UHHHHHH.
Mark: Why is there a slimy trail?
*shock*
*laughter* [Bob: No, no!]
Bob: Ah, yes!
Mark: NOO!
Wade: Oh, ho, ho.
Mark: What is that?
*laughter and disgust*
Bob: No, no, no!
Mark: Oh, my God.
Bob: Oh, my God. Wade: Come on, Bob...
Mark: Oh, ho, ho, no!
Wade: It's so hard to maneuver it, Mark.
Bob: Oh my God...
Mark: Oh, is that you? I thought that was Bob.
Wade: No, it's me.
Bob: No, just let me. Just let me.
Mark, help me out here.
Mark: How can I help you?
Bob: Help me. Bring your balls to me, Mark.
Mark: No, no, no, no. My buttballs will stay exactly where they are.
Bob: Give me your little buttballs.
Wade: I can't get in.
*laughter*
*gaming strains*
Mark: Oh, no, no!
*resolution*
Mark: EEEHHHH, OOOOOH, NO.
Bob: Why does that [Mark: How are you winning?] make it longer?
Mark: Wait, how are you winning? That doesn't make any sense.
Wade: Oh. Oh, no.
Bob: Nope, I got you.
Wade: NO, OHHHH.
Bob: Oh, God. Oh, God.
*more gaming blabber and weird noises*
Bob: Yee Haw!
Mark: Oh, NO.
Wade: I can't believe [Mark: Stop, stop.] ... I'm doing this.
Mark: STOP, STOP.
Bob: Get away...get away, OH *blabbers*
Mark: Ah, I'm comin for ya!
Mark: nnno-o~
*Mark Screaming* *laughter*
Mark: Oh, it's so visual.
It's so- how- seriously, how are you winning?
Bob: Well, I got more points!
Wade: I don't know!
I don't feel like I'm winning...
*random no's here and there*
Mark: I think- I think there's- OH!
Bob: GOTCHA!
Wade: Oh, God, I almost-
*more gaming cheering and struggle*
Bob: We went in a circle! Oh, my Go-hahah-d!
Mark: W-WHAT?!
Bob: Why did you get two points?! Oh, I got two points, good.
Mark: I got no points. No one got in me!
Bob: You didn't dick anyone.
Nope, noPE, NO
*laughter*
Bob: Got you, bitch.
Wade: Aw, I didn't get a chance to-
Mark: How did you get two?
Bob: I don't understand these points!
Mark: What the hell is this?
Bob: Do you want people to get in your - In your balls? Butt?
Mark: I think yes.
Bob: Oh, man!
Mark: Woah.
Wade: Left Bob out.
Bob: You guys suck.
Wade: I wanted to-
Mark: Why does that give me two points?
Wade: I don't-
Mark: WHY?
Wade: *crying* I don't know.
*laughter*
Mark: No one's going to get in THIS.
*profuse laughter*
Bob: Wait, wait - come here, no!
Mark: Oh, no.
Bob: Wait, so I got one even though I- I just-
Wade: All I did was go in you.
Bob: So, you want to be inside AND get inside.
Oh, God.
Wade: Oh, no.
Bob: Sweet Jesus.
Mark: Here, here, here, here. I'm presenting- [Bob: I got it.] I'm presenting- [Bob: I got it.]
Bob: Yeah!
Mark: Yayyyyy
Bob: I think that ?? two points.
Wade: NOOO Bob: Oh, it ?? two points
Mark: What the HELL?
Wade: oh, COME ON
Mark: Oh this game is so *unintelligable*
Bob: nope, nope, nope, nope.. OH GOD
[Game: PENETRATION]
*Laughter*
Bob: OOH, YES
*more laughing*
Mark: Oh so you guys get two points cuz you comboed, but if I just do it by myself...
Wade: I guess?
Mark: WHU- I- WHAT
Bob: Well, no one's gettin- no one's gettin this.
[Game: PENTRATION, PENETRATION]
Bob: I got my own self
Wade: I can't...uhm
Bob: Oh God, I unbutt-
Wade: AAAH Mark: WhOOOOa Bob: OH
Wade: Thanks for that...
Mark: Oh no. No...
Bob: WHAT
Mark: NooooOOOOAH
Bob: Oohph
Mark: oooOOOOh No
Wade (innocent): It's milk right?
Bob: Yeah, it's milk. It's-
Bob: ...Dick milk- is-
Mark: Yeah.
*Extremely awkward silence*
Mark: Let's un- Let's see this new costume we unlocked.
Mark: OH
Bob: Oh a police!
Bob: ...mans
Mark: Oh, so only one person can
Wade: Wait, how
Mark: Oh nope there we go.
Bob/Wade: How did you do that?
Mark: I don't know, I didn't do anything.
Wade: Welp..
Mark: GRRR Officer peen is comin' in
don't worry...
*Grunting*
AHHHHH
Bob: WERE NOT LONG ENOUGH!? OH, SWEET JESUS!
Oh God
Wade: I wish I- OHHHHHH
Everyone: OOOOh Bob: THE HATS COME OFF
Bob: Oh oh oh Noooooo
Mark: But again, how do you get two?
Mark: I got the first
Mark: I got the first in
Mark: Oh, no no, none for you, none for you
Bob: Yeah help me out Mark, help me out Mark
Mark: Nah nah nah nah WHOA no
Mark: WHOAAA NAH NAH
Bob: Mark would you stop pulling me the wrong way!
Mark: Get him, get him [Wade: COME ON!]
Mark: Get him, get him. Everybody: AHHHHHHHH
Bob: YEAHHHHH that is.. [Wade: *unintelligible mumbling* *Mark laughs*] Bob: ... horrifying
*Mark starts ranting* WHAT THE?! THAT DOESN'T....! IF I GET FIRST IN WHY IS THAT [*THE GAME WHISERS* PENETRATIONNNN] Mark: Yeah do that
*Wade laughs* Mark: I'm going for it. Bob: AHHH SHIT!
Mark: And that's... Bob: OH YES Wade: OHHHH Mark: WHOAAAA
*Bob laughing hysterically*
Mark: This scoring system means nothing
Wade: This is gonna make me feel sick *Mark makes goose sound*
Mark: Ok HUPPP. Bob: GOT YOU BITCH! Mark: Yeppppp you do that
Wade: OHHHH. Bob: NOPE NOPE NOPE
Bob: Ohhhhh. Mark: Hang on. Wade: Come on. Mark: NO NO NO
Bob: Not like this. Wade: Come on go. Bob: I'm protected.
Wade: No. Mark: No no no come on.
Bob: I'm fully protected here. Wade: Let me. Mark: No you won't. *Wade begs* Let me.
Mark: No you won't. Bob: Mark Mark oh
Mark: AHHHHHHHHH. Wade: NOOOOOOOO
YEAHHHHHHH
*Fart Sound* Wade: LET ME INNNN!
Wade: *crying* I don't wanna get in but I do
Bob: Hey you're actually called Mark!.
Mark: Yeah that's... Bob: That's good.
Mark: Alright [GAME: PENETRATIONNN] Bob: Oh no. Mark: Whoaa. Wade: Oh well.
Bob: Fine Whatever.
*Everybody Laughs*  Bob: I don't give a shit.
Bob: I'll get my own points
Mark: HAAA. Wade: Do you have a moustache?!
Mark: Hell yeah I do man. Bob: OH NO BUTT MOVE! [GAME: PENETRATION]
Wade: OHHHHH. Mark: Ohhhh you guys suck.
*Bob and Wade laugh hysterically at Mark*
*Bob mimicking Mark* Ohhh you guys fucking guys Mark: Fuck you guys. Bob: I'll just go fuck myself. Mark: Ahhhhh.
Wade: Oh my God. Mark: Oh my God.
Bob: Butt get out of there
Wade: WHAT?!. Mark: This isn't the right direction WHOOOP
Bob: Oh I see it I see it.
Bob: YEEHAW!. Wade: COME BACKKKK
Bob: Nope nope nope *Mark laughs*
Bob: Ah damn it. Wade: I feel so uncomfortable *squirt fart sounds*
Bob: Oh God *laughs*
Mark: Move that. [THE GAME: PENETRATION X2] Mark: Ow [Bob: ohhhhhh] Mark: my butt
Mark: Come on, come on, come on, come on OHHHHH
Bob: BOB'S GONNA WIN!. Mark: What?
HMMMM BLEUGHHHH *laughter* *fart squirt sounds*
Bob: OH, OH NO.
Wade: Eugh. Bob: Give me that!. Wade: No. Bob: Give me that butt
[THE GAME: PENETRATION X2]
Bob: Give me that!. Wade: AHHHHH. Bob: YES!
Bob: YES! BOB WINS!. Wade: Wait... Bob: BOB WINS!. Wait! Do we?...
Wade: We're all three of the same spot. Mark: Yeah. Bob: I got there first
Bob: Tied for victory?!. Mark: Looks like you're... ohhhhh
OH OH OH. Mark: Grab that.. NO. Wade: GOT IN.
Mark: My sweet butt... Wade: NOOO
Bob: OH NOOO YOU FUCKER GUYS
Mark: ON YOUR OWNNNN. Bob: You douche bags. Mark: HA OH JEEZ
Mark: Oh jeez
*Wade laughing* Mark: Oh geez oh no
Bob: Wow you guys are big (that's what she said)
[THE GAME: PENETRATION] *weird Mark noises*
*Laughter* Bob: You fuckers!
*Mark and Wade laugh hysterically*
Mark: Oh no oh no. Wade: Oh Bob *Bob laughs hysterically*   Mark: Oh no oh no
Mark: OHHHHHHHHHH *Bob continues to laugh*  Mark: Oh jeez
Wade: Well no no no [THE GAME: PENETRATION] Wade: YEP. Mark: NO
Mark: Let.. Let me in
Bob: Nope [THE GAME: PENETRATION] Mark: BOBBB
Bob: Ha ha ha fuck you. Mark: I  was gonna get up there. Wade: No NO
Mark: AH COME ON!
Wade: TIED?!
Bob: Ha you stil can't *laughs* Wade: we can't get any bigger
Mark: We can get bigger. Bob: I can catch up
Bob: This is happening
[THE GAME: PENETRATION] Bob: Oh shit
Mark: Whoop give me that *more random Mark noises*. Bob: Nope nope nope nope
Mark: It's right there!
Mark: IT'S RIGHT, I WAS RIGHT ON THAT!
*All* Nope nope NOOOOOO. Wade: Man that looked tasty
Bob: Wade! Come here! You lost you fucking idiot!
Mark: YEAHHHHHH.
Wade: I did? [Bob: You didn't get that second point because you didn't let me fuck you.]
Bob: I just needed to put it in your butt. [Mark: HEY HEY!]
Wade: I was gonna let you in. Mark: Forty inches?!
Bob: Why did you deny my love? [Wade: I don't know.]
Mark: Oh, God we're shooting confetti. Oh, no.
Bob: Wow.
All: Oh nooooooo.
Bob: Okay.
Mark: Eugh.
Bob: Game unlocked party mode.
Mark: Eugh. [Bob: Who wants to party?]
Mark: Well, maybe we can save that for the next episode.
Because- *Mark makes vomit noises*
Mark: Anyway, thank you everybody so much for watching.
Mark: Umm. [Bob: I like this screen, this screen is calm.]
Mark: Yeah this is the calm before the storm.
Bob: This makes me feel good.
Mark: The butt sex.
Bob: The calm before the cock.
Mark: Anyway, thanks for watching. Uhh, obviously this video is age-restricted.
So congrats for being the right age.
Bob: What would this possibly be age restricted for?
*Mark does an impression of a car braking*
I don't know.
But either way if you wanna see more of this let us know down in the comments below.
If you're horribly offended by this let us know down in the comments below.
If you never wanna see this ever again let us know in the comments below.
If you giggled even a little bit,
you're immature.
So, let us know down in the comments below. Thanks again everybody for watching, check out their links in the description.
And as always, we'll see YOU- in the next video. Buh-bye!
P3NI5!!!